c'est désormais l'une des meilleures
joueuses international de bridge
mathilde et willy 21 ans étudiante en
troisième année de médecine a raflé cet
été la médaille d'or de la discipline à
lyon dans la catégorie gurls par paire
sa passion pour ce sport s'est
construite entre ses murs à villiers
saint frédéric avec ses parents depuis
ses 8 ans mon mari joe masseur joue la
maman de marie jo ma maman joue la
famille aujourd'hui mathilde de vie
comme une vraie sportive la joueuse doit
faire attention à son alimentation et à
sa récupération avant les compétitions
pour s'entraîner lajaunie blinoise
participent à des tournois mensuels et à
des parties en ligne sur internet
donc là ma partenaire n est pas
disponible du coup je vais jouer contre
des robots mais c'est un petit peu le
même principe ça en était le vert une
fois voire semaines en soir on en 1h30
2h à l'entraînement régulier
indispensable pour avoir toutes les
cartes en main pour réussir des
compétitions
c'est un sport puisqu'il faut tenir
toute une après midi voire parfois toute
une après midi et toute une matinée
pendant plus d'une semaine et c'est un
entraînement sur toute l'année et en
plus il faut avoir une bonne condition
physique
parce que si on est si on est trop
fatigué par exemple on pourra pas jouer
on pourra pas tenir toute une semaine de
bridge prochain objectif pour mathilde
de revenir avec des médailles d'or des
championnats d'europe en croatie des
championnats du monde de shanghai de
compétition organisée l'été prochain